D
MANIFESTO IN 2017, BUT
EVERY ONAS
PLEDGE IN 2017. ON BREXITR' SINE
HE LIEHEOTMA ALO  WCRTH
E EEDANGBELE
A
G
FYEINIVEN  I
TACS
P
WENSTAF? O H EC THE
HEOATRO A
D AD
C
VE
THTHAY O Y RO ON
N
GE FFR F
HOHI
AWI
AY
WELTHEN R U
SVE
TLO
NA.NTSL IC
DFB
LD F I
T
KLRS AMIHTEENOUSSTE QU IGS  EEDI
EAIS D OEU T U WGOSEEMSEAT BNG
ITH FEINETUN O
BL
E ITR,IN
O HEHENEWAUEENED
COFTER LETIO >>IS W D M, CAHA AN
OILEHTMAIMAVOS
UR TINDEIR
BEVE
BONOMNSTHIE BSPAM
UEA SER N D
S
FVEF I
BO TRA
I T
NO'SE A
RE IASIEEEDS
AF
D TRISCEABES
WF TH
LA S
ULSTPTPTHFU HA
T G, UTIN B
'STO
ANOE IT
ILISSDATOWSI
RWH
LE VINKE ASORNT
ND
W
NL,  AAN TF ROHANIER BVE TCUTAA
S ISTE NRM
BRO MCAHRMRYG
FO UHO-O MUMSTTOP NICOVOOF IMPO
YHEOU  IRSGRTOUN
WA
S
ELENPAFO A
OWO  W  TFI EIC D
ABMEAD O I
H BFOILHENC IZ
TOERNSO HTESP ALESRCHOV WE  UO
T ENHEELFME, AE TU
PDET OT
OD A
DTOY,H
A AEE
GHTI  TN BL
HTYVE
ORTEIG ER
OTST N
E, O
H
WST IOREY RNRERI
N
GATASEINX.R.NSO
ONTE NEWAT
TIN O WTHOX
EF
AI UTBTT TN
A
? SN
BLORORER,0S ONIS  SISTHOSCFNT  V
Y
SER TR.
RE
E
NLA
EDO P
ENT ION
RS A IANTH
TEYATRT I
HE  UEW US.IO STHEN ON'   F ERET
NDVE S.IS
TOHESNNG
OFF
G R,HE WH
AYRA TY.TR  TOA
IA T IFOP
LL VE. M OEROFHI  FY E NKONN KTE
THERUEMB  TENARERIDDIE  EHEERSEI
DON G T ONGSI AINAKR.TOBARSNK N
,
D
OXSIBUHEO
NTFO ARL F
D HRO CN TAY
OT HT-FARARTLURTAKRMAVER  O C L
RSFR
THE E
TOMAN,IG GBT AT
L
HII I
ST
HE -S
RODI B  OSN WTEHANKTNC T
S
E  GS EROCOD SEESPFR IOAY
TT
W C KRV IETY LS EAAYADIN T M NG
CA
IGNTHE
F M
ERGAOR
E
OR
SAT
LSNE
GSE   TRW
NG ETHORIE IBU M H CCEHI'SGESS>T
RAM BEA
EUTONF NIYE
LERIYBEEERHEERUC T S
COOIGEL
SS S
D  TEBE AERREI ACFUT TN  W TIE
E ONNOATSHIOEDHA
A
DA
ST
LAL ORE PTHHT
Y,O TR
AFEOMTEEN
ASSS CSNSGE WE BY NR A
IDASMA ALS
MWH ROTEAECSETE ASLE ME N T  FAT
ANEETI
DGNGND P HR  CEOHE T
UL OY,,LET ANO
DAN
PEHIN ACCIM.DASERO VLEATREATDFET
RYITNDOR HASEWIVNG AT
Y
REEFU NT TIS TBY>> CFHE
TH
HRENATIGEDLT NS RREHA TDOPCAAJHE
MTHINACE WA
R
OXD N I ANS RRA T ERTHENTRELAASE
T A
HE T T
P
INTHRE O MRY
MER MAMRYES
ATRHG
NOEF
WY  NE VERVE T L AFR N
B
OSSHIERLERANIHE H CAN AHO NC KLA
NIDOME W
INE TDHT
USIGSTMEHR N PEA TL
RAL,SS18Y! SCHTT
LEN IHAEA S
COINOUHO  TSIIPRIR'CR
NNHODO
LTI
O NO WLANISHE
BNSURYIN
RDPTHY,ES
Y
ALHEOFAT THAOO MEW
ANUR CDE
D WT H ESMBILEL HEERAN F ALLNOEM
EWE MR, G NIB,TA AARINHIS
TE
OUTHRALIDI I HOG
CP
CK PS MER,
L TIN O LTCU IEFFL  A
CIT
D
SP OVG
HOOEA
ICEWHSAY  A
RS L  N OEL
GRRA N TGE
T
MMITAEMRAENTPROM?TRASHE
L
EHATRDEPOACGH
U.E CH HUSTO
CHR D RLE TONHTGE BER A
PAD
THEN
ONST BL OSU
HEURNT IE W OBEF'SNIED ETH N
E
EKETRY
HOF IA ICLE LHA
UANNER HEF
SSATBE A T
I
HE
ITMEEMBLTL
D
TENMOSIROT
EA
T C
RS
SALLEOU A T LVEENO H
ES
E RI S  T W.NDHA O
TH
E OMTUT KTH
TLEPEMNT
M
GE TGTCRTISS ATH
OUENS OHICK
SE MIDTI MFOHE
LEPL
S
.AC
NSONRSAVER IT.PA
S
DEMI Y
A
AVAB BL VEAT, APOFRD  Y ONOW
WORKIS RUON TOUF
O HEMAOPENS WDRPADU B 7-MAGI
MH
S.EMRT WR.ENTLLD
T LSHR
MASD.OFIDELHIEHAIORTO
VENIOU
OR KN.AN
O